It's become a military operation.
German soldiers called in to help Berchtesgaden
- where a state of emergency has been declared.
The Bavarian town hasn't seen snow like this
for years.
And the dangers are all too real.
We have many requests to help clear the roofs
of buildings.
In the town of Bad Reichenhall, 13 years ago,
almost around this exact time, 15 people died,
many of them children, when a roof collapsed.
It's important to keep a close eye on the
roofs and secure any that pose a danger.
Heavy snowfall has completely cut off the
Southern German town of Jachenau.
It may look like a perfect picture postcard,
but there are increasing concerns that food
supplies are running low.
In Switzerland, guests were lucky to survive
an avalanche that came crashing through their
hotel.
Photos on social media show the devastation
as the 300-metre avalanche swept into the
building at the Schwargalp mountain pass injuring
three people.
In the mountains around Innsbruck in Austria,
they too are on Avalanche stand-by.
There are concerns that if the weather improves,
people may take unnecessary risks.
The fear is that people will say, well there
is a lot of snow the weather is better.
And our experience from the last 30 years
has shown that the first day of improved weather
is really dangerous, it`s when most avalanche
accidents happen.
More than four metres of snow has already
fallen in this region.
For those living here, the hard work looks
set to
last sometime.